welcome to this video playing the guitar
from Belgium that's the national master
Stefan docs played him just recently and
lost from the very nice position in the
English opening so I really want to do
but i am going from my pet tzimisce
variation jack is some not playing
instantly now you can go to e7 it's not
totally totally crazy but it's very
rarely played okay he's gained going for
this somewhat conservative set up with
already being cancelled I mean I've had
a number of games here where I had very
nice positions from that okay let me
consider G for this night g six maybe
yeah that's interesting that's
interesting tribe trying to play f5
quickly g 496
that's interesting it stops each form
yeah it's still the right move
strategically I think about damn turkey
let's see what happens I think I still
am right in preventing a five just
mechanically preventing a five it's not
really i can do that now on I g6 sh5
that's surprising is is thinking along
completely different lines okay yeah
that's funny about chess sometimes I
have completely different ideas I really
thought you wanted to go to g6 okay just
protected for the moment okay let's see
he will play Bishop a for what is the
idea Queen a for maybe Queen their form
possible
Bishop f4 I can play Queen B 1 there is
no big problem with that now these got
some pressure against you for but I
don't know I don't really think it
should be too too great okay the
question is how to proceed here night f5
is one possibility g5 is a move various
good ideas okay I'll start with that one
problem sometimes can be in this is
closed structure if you let all your
Knights exchange that you have the
bishop pair but it's not so clear what
the bishops are actually doing so must
be must be cautious with exchanges
allowing exchanges like that and so I
still didn't see a way to prevent it but
it's okay i think g5 root g three years
the idea sometimes if you don't have a
night in this position you have the
don't really know how to to to make any
progress in terms of sacrifices and then
other things um okay should I am play up
you won or not it's not threatening
Knight c3 because of Queenie one but
maybe not be too I can't be sure play
Bishop c2 okay let me prepare g5 him
I thought Bishop c2 would be okay maybe
he's got be five then I can also just
let him take it yeah maybe not waste any
more time this also should threaten g6
so like we probably need to react react
to it not sure I've g6 the threat but it
could be okay now my next idea would be
king king edge to rook g1 try to use of
the g file okay okay I go g6 no no way
I'm not doing that then check here yeah
there is h4h this this advanced and I
need to need the King a way to have root
g one
and you know this will be dangerous a
nice counter plays be 5m ok 1b5 Queenie
3s stresses dangerous threatening rook
g7 ok I only have one minute something
so cannot calculate the cern to the end
p 523 this is dangerous came so i have
also looked reform brooke g6 maybe to
have rook takes f6 tough when you
minutes something this is tough to play
also Bishop h6 ok now I try to get in
Queen g3
use some all pieces bishop age six to
three
sure h6 is not really threatening
anything i don't i don't know this looks
weird but i want to use the atrium
I cannot play this mmm that's that sets
a problem
okay cannot I cannot really do my more
Jam Wow my thought night at five but
this is maybe even stronger and now it's
got Quinn takes h4 and okay normal right
cuz I a very tough game the kind of
position where white is again certainly
a very much better but very difficult to
play right here I really don't believe
in blacks position not not at all but
it's difficult to play I'm very
difficult to play another computer gives
avoid an advantage but it's not clear
cut maybe this is probably wrong am this
is wrong am King h3 is wrong because I
cannot really attack now without the h
porn and and I just use too much time h5
is much stronger with age 6 coming that
was really a bad move King age three
now again here black must defend very
carefully because I will be I will be
much much quicker now compared to the
game if you look at this you probably
must set up in this kind of way and then
it just continues to be a dangerous
attack rook h1 maybe it looks dangerous
but black is still fairly solid
the other computer the computer wants to
play it for him prophylactic move and
give us a lighter so much have a pawn I
mean that's not the end of the world
maybe I should have fully kept the the
bishop here but yeah I think it was it
was pretty ok whatever I did the the
point one other problem that say was
that this is this is not good really
it's still not not totally clear but I
lose time I just lose time compared to
the other way to attack and here it's
it's tricky well this is not a happy
move but it's hard to make any progress
here the night is just protecting those
squares and there is 96 at the right
moment this is already quite
substantially better for black yeah and
boy I hoped for that move but
well here 95 is just winning Quincy
force was strong not allowing this night
f5 business yeah until I have no move
yeah very tough alright thanks for
watching